Fox News Alert a brand new photo showing
the two American hostages who were
released by the Hamas terrorists Judith
ran and her 18-year-old daughter Natalie
who are from outside Chicago are now
with Israeli forces and undergoing
Medical Care Mike Tobin is in southern
Israel with more
Mike well Natalie and Judith R nonjudge
from Evanston Illinois are released from
Hamas captivity they're out of the Gaza
Strip they are either at an Israeli base
in southern Israel now are headed in
that direction where they are scheduled
to be reunited with family some of their
family members have already been on
Special Report expressing their hopes to
get their loved ones
released the Hamas terrorist had brought
them into one of the family's house uh
they stayed there they GA the Hamas
gathered them with another family and
they brought the both of them in
there and uh the eyewitness told us that
about 30 minutes later they handcuffed
Judith and Natalie and both of the men
that were there after murdering one of
of her daughters that was lying dead in
the other room we're very anxious to be
able to reunite them with their loved
ones we welcome their release we share
in the relief that their families
friends and loved ones are
feeling but there are still 10
additional Americans who remain
unaccounted for uh in this conflict
every single one of them should be
released Natalie and Judith were met at
the Crossing into Gaza or out of Gaza by
gal hir he is a retired Israeli General
who was bought out of retirement by
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu and
given the task this very difficult task
of securing the release of now 198
hostages believed to be held by uh Hamas
and Islamic Jihad it should be noted
that both the US and Hamas gave credit
to the qataris for striking the deal
that secured their release judge all
right Mike stay safe thanks so much and
the release of two American hostages
might complicate Israel's imminent
ground Invasion Republican candidate
Nikki Haley warning it could be Hamas
trying to buy time and
delay two prayers have been answered and
we've got 200 more to go that's the
first thing I'll say the second thing
I'll say to the Biden Administration is
don't fall for it what they're doing is
they're going to throw two hostage out
there for one to see if they can weaken
us to keep Israel from going into um
Gaza and two because they want to see if
they can get something out of
it okay Jesse I'll start with you why
these two the uh there're over 200 as I
understand it hostages why to Americans
why not israelies I mean they had a
whole group to choose from I probably
shouldn't say it but American hostages
in terms of the international landscape
very valuable especially when we're
sponsoring the Israeli assault through
these weapons
transfers they're trying to drive a
little bit of a wedge here I understand
the tactic Iran is involved the qataris
are kind of tangentially involved and
Hamas is involved because this is the
only leverage they have they've been
doing this begging other Arabs to get
involved in this assault they're not
despite a few missiles from Yemen and
this is their other way of saying hey
guys you know what if you just halt this
ground Invasion we'll release the
hostages I'm not buying it I'm not
buying it they could do a drip drip drip
and I don't think Israel right now is as
concerned with returning hostages as
they are with decimating Hamas so
they're going to go in pretty soon and
they're going to go in with f-16s
they're going to with bulldozers tanks
drones and the Infantry is going to go
house to house door to door and it's
going to be ugly and then they're going
into the tunnels and they're going to go
in with tunnel rats with knives and
maybe even flood them and the goal it
looks like is to push half the
population South into Southern Gaza and
create a
northern I wish maybe like a DMZ where
there's no Hamas there I guess they kind
of have control over the situation maybe
you give it like a buffer
designation and I don't know if they're
going to have time to do that they say
that they're going to do this for a year
they don't have a year because as this
ground assault develops all of these
Arabs who are angry already are going to
be watching Al jazer and Jordan and
Saudi Arabia and Lebanon and they're
going to see the devastation the
destruction and it's going to look
really bad so they're going to mount
mobs against embassies they're going to
scream into the air and it's going to
get tense and so it's does the United
States and and does Israel
do they have the focus and the
determination to let this ground assault
play out no matter what the pr
collateral damages um I just been
advised that President Biden has spoken
by phone with the family of the two
Americans who've been released um so
that is a good thing but but let me go
to you Katie what kind of intelligence
do you think we can gather from these
two women who've been released well they
certainly know maybe where they were
held but they also could have been
blindfolded they they were blindfolded
on the way into good the Gaza Strip
clearly they don't know exactly where
they were they may be of course they can
talk about how they were treated which I
can't imagine the things that they went
through um but they're going to need
some time too to really think about what
has happened to them and they deserve
some space uh the intelligence will take
care of itself when it comes to what the
Israelis know what the US knows in terms
of their hostage negotiation um we're
grateful for their release obviously but
it's a very low bar for Hamas and they
should be given no Goodwill and that
goes for Qatar as well when it comes to
this release there as the Secretary of
State mentioned 10 Americans who are
still unaccounted for 30 Americans were
killed as a result of this incursion and
Hamas is using hostages in the Gaza
Strip as human Shields to as a way to
avoid accountability and to avoid
uh accountability for what they've done
and what they did and the American amans
need to push the Israelis to do what
they have to do to get this job done
there is not a lot of time in space for
this to happen um and especially if
we're going to be sending in Aid without
any conditions of releasing hostages as
well when there are photos of Hamas
using aid from UNESCO during their
assault in Israel so I hope they can be
helpful in terms of giving um the
Americans and Israel intelligence to
free other hostages but given there's
hundreds of miles of tunnels be very
difficult to use anything maybe that
they came up with to find the others you
know uh Jessica there are there are
people who are giving Hamas credit
saying you know um the showing of The
humanitarian side but you don't try to
obliterate a people and burn people
alive and kill children to go to sleep
in their own beds and then suddenly
become humanitarian do you no I I don't
think so and I think it is important
that people when they discuss this
massacre can continue to reiterate the
details of it that they pulled babies
from their beds that they gouged their
eyes out that they took grandparents who
had survived the Holocaust who needed
urgent medical care didn't care raped
women went to a peaceful music festival
um and did the most gruesome things you
could ever imagine pure barbarism so
what they did is they did something
smart and strategic at this moment
Jesse's completely right they had to go
with Americans first because we are the
ones that are funding all of this we
also know from past precedent that
Israelis will trade a lot for hostages
they have before traded up to a thousand
people for one Israeli to come home now
I think it's important there are only 15
million of us on the planet right now of
Jews 6 million of us were exterminated
every life counts but you better believe
the terrorists know that that's how
Netanyahu thinks about it that's not how
Joe Biden thinks about it necessarily
it's a different kind of game that he's
playing thinking about what's going to
happen from the north what happens he
said last night we have to hold Iran
accountable what does that look like we
don't know yet but we know that we're
watching them and see if they get
involved I want to repeat something
though from yesterday that General Pat
Ryan the spokesman at the Pentagon said
that's really important said you have to
trust us that we know more than you do
and that's very clear that two hostages
are out today hopefully it will increase
on a daily basis that we get more and
more out and then we can continue to
squeeze them and that they are so afraid
of what's coming that they let all 200
of these people out but people need to
have more confidence in the American
government and in the Israeli government
that they know more than we do and they
are working day and night to make sure
that these two is just the start of the
floodgates and they are the experts the
American and and the Israelis Greg and
the truth is I mean that you know if you
keep delaying and what we saw I think it
was yesterday we saw prime prime
minister Netanyahu talking to the forces
it's what you generally see with any any
of leader talking to the forces before
they go into war and then all of a
sudden there was a lull today because of
the
negotiations when do they go in now I
don't know I'm no expert on Military but
I do know the media pretty well and at
the blink pressor a reporter used the
hostage release to say isn't this a
moment for a pause I.E cease fire which
again we can all pretty much agree as
part of the Hamas plan look they hold
the cards they have 200 hostages so they
might be doing this to buy time just to
get in the right place to inflict more
damage and this is part of a PR crusade
to stop a ground or put off a ground
Invasion uh we're not really that bad
after all we didn't really kill as many
people as you think and they're hoping
that our media will treat it as such the
media as we've seen this week are really
good at being used and this is the
problem and the challenge of the micro
coverage of this war Hamas exploits it
they know that we react to every single
they do and you have to be aware that
they have an alterior motive because
they know that which is why it's
important it's important for us and As
Americans and these viewers to step back
and ignore those who say oh maybe the
threat is exaggerated they just released
H hostages you know this is their
stragedy this is their tragedy it's good
to be hopeful we're glad they're
released but do not be naive This Moment
by moment coverage requires an ongoing
commentary that is at the mercy of
confusion usion nobody knows anything
and you're right it's what we don't know
that matters right so I say pull back
assess with patience the speculation
about first second or third fronts and
impending ground invasions and delaying
tactics and who's going to do what stop
Israel has decided their course the
release of these hostages is good but
then anticipate something bad because
that's War this is this you may think
it's a humanitarian gesture I don't
think so okay okay we're following the
breaking news on the two freed American
hostages hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else